قاده السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي في عده دول داخل اوبك وخارجها
باجمال مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل حتى نهايه العام الجاري
وستخفض كلا من السعوديه وروسيا انتاجهم من
النفط بواقع خمسمائه الف برميل يوميا لكل
منهما فيما ستخفض الامارات الانتاج بعدد
144 الف برميل يوميا ثم الكويت بعدد 128
الف برميل كما اعلنت الجزائر ايضا عن خفض
طوعي بثمانيه واربعين الف برميل من النفط
يوميا تلك القرارات تسببت في ارتفاع اسعار
النفط لتسجل اكبر زياده يوميه منذ نحو عام
حيث قفز خام برنت بواقع خمسه وتسعه عشر في
المئه حتى لامس اعلى مستوى له في شهر عند
86 دولار ويعادل اجمالي تخفيضات اوبل بلس
نحو اربعه في المئه من الطلب العالمي
قاده السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي من دول داخل اوبيك ومن خارجها
باجمالي مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه العام الجاري
وفسرت الخطوه بانها اجراء احترازي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتوازن في اسواق الخام وفي
التفاصيل ستخفض السعوديه انتاجها من النفط
ب 500 الف برميل يوميا فيما ستخفض
الامارات الانتاج ب 144 الف برميل يوميا
والكويت ب 128 الف برميل يوميا كما اعلنت
الجزائر خفضا طوعيا بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل يوميا كذلك اعلن العراق انه سيخفض
الانتاج ب 211,000 برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت
سلطنه عمان خفضا باربعين الف برميل يوميا
كذلك اعلنت كازاخستان عن خفض طوعي
بانتاجها
يوميا فيما اعلنت الجابون عن خفض بثمانيه
الاف برميل يوميا وفي موسكو اعلن نائب
رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكزر نوفاك ان
بلاده ستمدد خفضا طوعيا بانتاجها من النفط
بواقع 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى نهايه
العمل جاري من متوسط مستوى الانتاج وفقا
لتقييمات مصادر ثانويه لشهر فبراير
وسيضاف هذا الخفض الى الخفض الذي اعلنه
تحالف اوبيكلاس في اكتوبر 2022
والذي قضى بخفض بمليوني برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العام الجاري هذا وكانت اسعار النفط
قد تراجعت الشهر الماضي الى ادنى مستوى
لها في 15 شهرا بالقرب من 70 دولارا
للبرميل وفى ازمه المصارف الامريكيه وتدخل
الحكومه السويسريه لانقاذ كريدي سويس ما
يجري دينيه العربيه من الخبر ينضموا الينا
خبير استراتيجيات الطاقه نايف مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذه الخطوه بالخفض
الطوعي من دول اوبك ودول خارج ايضا
هل هو خوف من انتقال عدوى الاسواق الماليه
المصرفيه وما حدث ايضا في الشهر الماضي ام
هي خطوه يمكن تبريرها بانها تستبق ربما
انخفاض الطلب المتوقع على النفط خلال
الايام القادمه
ويمكن ايضا بانها نظره غير متفائله
للاسواق تعتاب اي ظرف يمكن تصنيف هذه
الخطوه
مساء الخير الحقيقه عده عوامل اجتمعت
لاتخاذ مثل هذا القرار في الخفض الكبير
اللي هو بوينت
سكس اول هذه الخطوات طبعا بالتاكيد هي
خطوه احترازيه خطوه استباقيه ولكن اذا
ننظر للي حصل مثلا في فبراير في فبراير
اعلنت روسيا
تخفيض طوعي بمعدل 500 الف برميل يوميا
وادخل حيز التنفيذ في شهر ثلاثه او شهر
مارس ولكنه لم يكن مؤثرا الحقيقه ولم
يؤثر في استقرار
وتوازن الاسواق وبالتالي كان هناك حاجه
لاتخاذ خطوات اكبر من قبل دول اوبك بلس
وعلى راسها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وبقيه اهل
الدول الخوف او هاجس من انهيار اسعار
النفط تحت سعر السبعين دولار سيد نايف
والله هو كان الحقيقه انخفاض اسعار النفط
كان مقلق جدا لانه لم يعني لم يكن متصل
باساسيات الاسواق والحقيقه كان عده ضغوط
منها الضبابيه العاليه في الاسواق
العالميه منها
الانهيارات التي تحدث في البنوك والمصارف
سواء الاوروبيه او الامريكيه الان في قرار
ايضا قرار الاداره الامريكيه بعدم ملء
المخزونات الاستراتيجيه الحقيقه كان اشاره
مقلقه لانه
في استهداف لاسعار محدده يعني كانت تستهدف
بسعر 67 دولار
للبرميل حتى تملا مثل هذه المخزونات
الاستراتيجيه التي وصلت الى ادنى مستوى
لها منذ اربعين عام طيب مقدار خفض الانتاج
الطوعي بالنسبه لهذه الدول التي ذكرناها
في بدايه هذا الخبر هو مليون و6
60 الف اذا اضفنا اليها ايضا مجموع ما تم
خفضه في اكتوبر الماضي نصبح امام ثلاثه
ملايين و166 الف برميل يوميا هل يعتبر هذا
اليوم في اسواق النفط ولمستقبل اسواق
الطاقه لاستقرارها الاستقرار الاسعار هل
يعتبر تدخل في الوقت المناسب ام هو تدخل
متاخر نوعا ما
اعتقد انه في الوقت المناسب الا احنا لو
تاخر القرار هذا في في
الاشهر القادمه اعتقد انه سيكون متاخر
لسبب لانه ليش ما هو متاخر لانه روسيا في
الشهر الماضي تقدمت بخفض طوعي مقداره 500
الف برميل يوميا وبالتالي كان على الدول
اوبك بلس ان تقيم الخطوه وترى هل هي كافيه
هل هي مؤثره هل ستجلب الاستقرار والتوازن
للاسواق وبالتالي درست مثل هذه الخطوه ما
كانت مؤثره وروسيا كانت عندها مشكله
الحقيقه في انخفاض الاستهلاك المحلي
وبعدين راحت في انتاج اعلى
للاسواق العالميه فما كان مؤثر الحقيقه
لخفض الروسي مع هذا الخفض الاسعار قفزت
بمقدار
5.19% يعني لامست تقريبا 86 دولار هل
نتوقع زياده في الاسعار خلال
الاشهر القادمه بدايه من مايو وهو الشارل
التي الذي سيبدا فيه الخفض بشكل فعلي
انا ما اعتقد انه في ارتفاع كبير في
الاسعار راح اكثر من من اللي شهر طبعا
ممكن يكون في في ارتفاع طفيف اكثر من
المعدل لسبب لانه الاسواق الان حركه اسواق
النفط اصبحت ثقيله جدا ولا تعتمد على
الحساسيات التي كنا نشهدها في في السابق
ولانه هناك الحقيقه ضغوط فهناك عوامل دافع
دافعه وهناك عوامل تساعد على الضغط على
الاسواق فاحنا في يعني في ظروف مثاليه او
مثل هذا الخط اتى حتى يقفز في الاسعار هو
عباره عن
توازن بين الظروف التي تدفع اسعار النفط
الى الاسفل وما بين
التخفيض الذي قد يعزز
ما اظن انه في ارتفاع هائل بسبب حركه
النفط الثقيله في الفتره الاخيره ممتاز
الظروف خفض الانتاج الطوعي هذا اللي يعلن
عنها امس قبل الاجتماع ب 24 ساعه هل تشابه
ذات الظروف التي خفض فيها الانتاج في
اكتوبر الماضي 2022
الحقيقه في عامل مشابه عامل اللي هو عباره
عن تهديدات
الركود ودخول في تباطؤ اقتصادي كان في
اكتوبر
واثبت صحته الحقيقه لما باتخاذ هذا القرار
لانه شاهدنا في الاشهر التي تلت اكتوبر
فعلا هناك في تباطؤ واقتصادي وفي هناك
ظروف واقتصاديه ما تدعو للنمو الان الوضع
مختلف تماما كمان لانه في في انهيارات في
المصارف وفي تخوف شديد من المستثمرين وفي
عدم وصول السيوله الى ايدي المستثمرين في
حتى في القطاعات النفطيه او حتى في اسواق
تداول النفط تشديد السياسات النقديه ووصول
معدل الفائده الى هذا المستوى هذا حد من
وصول المستثمرين الى السيوله السهله خلينا
نقول مثل ما حصل في السابق وبالتالي
التداول عن النفط مثل ما ذكرت اصبح صعب
والحركه اسواق النفط اصبح ت اكثر ثقلا
الان